you've ever burnt the roof of your mouth
on pizza yeah holding that I'm Nicky
this is Andrew we're in a show called
eating your feed this is actually
they'll eating your feet a logo official
eating your feed merge cute yeah so
today we're rewatching episodes of
eating your feed personally selected by
Adam Bianchi this will shows him just
making fun of us I think for her this
first video mozzarella
today we're watching a tasty video
called oh yeah was the season finale of
season 1 yeah right off the bat I can
declare that this was the hardest thing
we've ever had to make this harder than
your hand pulled noodles hand-pulled
noodles I think was more maybe overall
frustrating both required making a pale
blob fun fact about this show we often
have to do dumb stuff to cover up the
brand of computer we use so here we have
six post-it notes usually it's like a
paper towel with a drawing that one of
us makes I know you're a cheese store
but I'm looking to make my own fun fact
that was my first iPhone 5 I had it for
five years
look at my face is that you yeah this
shows mostly you making faces well I
save dumb words save dumb stuff to sloth
use a third I cannot believe that this
one ingredient determines so much of our
success in failure we drop counts okay
it's been 37 sister the thing about
baking and cooking they always tell you
read the whole recipe first this whole
show is an example of what happens when
you don't do that I've never learned
that lesson clearly
oh no wait we were supposed to set it
aside for another five minutes see don't
read instructions
much of the liquid is I don't know what
mozzarella tastes like right now with
his face he's so upset about what we
just made
I'm still pretty rubbery just doesn't
have like that rich dairy taste this was
hey this episode was particularly
upsetting because we did not know what
we were doing wrong well we just each
make our own badges we were like oh yeah
we were it's why Adam keeps putting us
together this was just very long day I'm
sorry like two or three hitting you okay
so here is where we discover that the
previous batch that we thought was a
failure actually just needed a long time
something's happening something's
happening I was like cannot believe how
can we put it on everything and we like
ate like 12 pizzas that night okay
who's called the cheese bomb at a
restaurant in London called Maxwell's
another cheese episode half the episodes
are cheese
the other half were Japanese the other
what are you doing I don't know I just
have to keep pressing it until something
yet this is everything you need to know
about cooking really enter I don't know
I'm just gonna keep pushing it until
something happens I don't know I just
have to keep pressing it until something
happens we add cheese to this bechamel
that's amore you get that joke keep
playing it yeah that's amore keep play
any laugh get some more name oh I think
we definitely yeah did you get my job I
got your joke will you box hunt about
the song but it was wrong do you know
the song yes you sing it every time this
is such a disaster I can't even cook a
burger without like almost setting off
the fire alarm
we do all take a safety course yeah of
like cooking in this space and like what
to do and home not to hurt ourselves we
were violating so many rules here which
is why i Adam needed to or were we or is
it just the funny joke for the video
that was conscripted and safe Wow it
looks like a Crabby buddy did you hear
my oh yes voice yeah that's when people
were like oh it's him we are one of the
original tasty men me and Adam you and
Adam yeah made tasty essentially change
to the internet truly oh yeah you went
first oh good you ain't like half of the
burger like you're swimmin in time
it's like fondue but instead of a dip
it's a pour the hilarious oh this is
disgusting yeah yeah you can see the
body beautiful pork a pre-determined the
macarons are disgusting I felt bad doing
this for the macarons it looks so cool
though so today we made a delicious
liquid cheese sauce I think we nailed
this cheese sauce yeah we did a great
job they cut out the part where you and
I almost drink
remember that but you chickened out at
the last minute so I did not have to
that makes me want to kind of gag yeah
yeah that was one of the easier easier
ones Oh God okay look that told you yeah
paper towel with a face drawn on it
uncovering your computer oh yeah there
it is and those are eating your fee
difference there they aren't fromage Oh
what am i doing you could hear how hard
it is it was way too long oh I broke it
Oh
okay the editors are savage on this show
because to watch all of the footage that
we share is a lot look at what how they
do it they just they hate us okay
[Music]
the new thing you know chokers came back
into style this is a doaker so you're
just losing it a month later I just
don't have a delicate enough to touch to
do it yet I need to correct it graze
like delicate touch she makes magic oh
hell yeah baby that's not noodles I just
faking it I was like oh yeah noodles I
got it cuz I remember Adam just kept
being like that looks close enough and
you would be like no I didn't make
noodles it just you didn't the noodles I
was after which is the even strands you
mean the one that the man who's trained
for decades yeah why can I do that after
four days come on you did it so much my
skin in there yeah
just a bowl of sketch just Andrew oils
the noodles earlier question my dander
center what's next mochi we can't do
that no really heavy you look like you
really like yeah this is a vision we
were all together and then after this
time Adam was like never again is there
were too many info it's impossible to
get anything done it was so much fun oh
yeah very fun look this was another two
days this is yeah this is different it's
less slushy it's mushy oh yeah look at
that they're doing great
I was so scared I was like I hurt Rea
and this the Internet's gonna come to my
house and kill me oh this was
with the seaweed and this point I had
only ever had mochi as a thing so
learning that people eat it as a savory
thing was ya mind blowing okay that's
you getting that shot yeah so many just
close-up shots of me putting stuff in my
mouth this show most of this shows me
just mean like so that was some of our
favorite craziest moments from eating
your feed
hi Adam I was back for the part of the
outro say all the mean stuff about him
what a show the effort is real the drama
is real and the successes are like that
much more real which is very fun yeah so
thanks for watching if you want to watch
us watch more of this stuff that we've
already seen ourselves do feel free
comment
we'll be watching the comment studies
[Music]